（謎の音楽）
うわああ↑あああああ！！
（コンコン）
（ガチャ）
（バタン）
（カンカラン）
助手「先生 全員集まりました。」
？「一体何なんですか探偵さん、こんな所に人を集めて。」
ℋ「今回皆さんにお集まりいただいたのは他でもありません。」
？₂「こっちは忙しいんだよ　早くしてくれよ」
？「私も仕事で車の修理をしてただけなんですよ。早く次に行かせて下さい。」
助手「落ち着いて下さい。」
？₂による舌打ち
ℋによる咳払い
ℋ「実は先程　この家で殺人事件がありました。」
（シャン）×3
？「え」
？₂「おい疑ってんのかおい」
？₃&？₄止めに入る
助手「皆！落ち着いて落ち着いて」
？₂による舌打ち
助手「あ゛？」
ℋ「今回の事件の被害者は三段ノ腹洋平さん、32歳
職業はYouTuberで間違いないですね？」
助手「はい。間違いありません。
現在は長期の休暇を取っているため三日前からしばらく在宅しています。」
？₃「はいィ。間違えありません。」
ℋ「あなたたちは？」
？₄「私共は三段ノ腹様のお家で家事を担当しております、灰山と灰川と申します。」
ℋ「なるほど。」
ℋ「確か灰川さん、あなた死体の第一発見者でしたよね。」
灰川「はいィ。」
ℋ「死体を発見したのはいつ頃でしたか？」
灰川「私目の記憶が正しければ確か…お昼の12時頃だったと思います。
台所でお料理をしておりまして叫び声が聞こえたなあと思って旦那様の様子を窺いに行ったところ…
うっ…(息継ぎ)旦那様あ(息継ぎ)どうして…(息継ぎ)何でえ(過呼吸気味)」
灰山「灰川さん。」
（こいつやべえ）
（耐えろ耐えるんだ俺！！）
？₂「どうせお前らが殺ったんだろ？日頃の恨みとかで」
灰山「いいえ私たちが三段ノ腹様を殺す理由なんてありません！」
？₂「うるせえ早く白状しろよ！」
助手「決めつけるのはまだ早い。」
？₂による舌打ち
（・・・）
（沈黙）
ℋ「第一発見者の灰川さん。」
（な、なんや）
ℋ「あなたが最初に死体を見ていた時に握っていた物、覚えてますか。」
（ト、トマトですゥ）
ℋ「灰川さん、あなたが私と出会った時あなたの手には…
包丁が握られていたあ！！！」
（シャン）×5
？「ほれみろやっぱりお前らが犯人じゃん。私は仕事に戻らせてもらうよ。」
（ヒュン）
ℋ「いえ。まだ彼が犯人という確証はありません。」
？「はあ？」
ℋ「殺害の方法に関しては不明ですが犯行現場の近くには血まみれの包丁がなぜか2つ落ちてました。」
？「２つ？」
ℋ「他に怪しい物が無かったため恐らく死因は刺殺でほぼ確定だと思います。」
？₂「ちょっと待てよ。どうして２つも包丁が？」
ℋ「１つは分かりませんがもう１つの包丁は…
（キッ）
灰川さん、あなたのですよね。」
（スンッ）
助手「ん？ちょっと待った灰山さん、あなたの手に…
血の跡があ↗！！なんじゃこりゃあ！！」
（シャン）×2
ℋ「灰山さん、あなた事件の直前何してらっしゃいましたか。」
灰山「わ、わ、私はただこの新米の灰川の料理を見てただけなんです。
この手の血はきっと灰川がついつい間違えて私を刺してしまってその時に出血した血の跡だと思います。」
（痛がる灰山謝る灰川）
灰山「この血は料理中に灰川がついつい間違えて私を刺してしまってその時に出血した血です。
これが先程灰川に切られた怪我です。」
（シュッ）
？「すーごい血じゃないか。早く病院に行きなさい。」
助手「片方の包丁の血は灰山さんの血ということですね。」
灰山「ということはもう一本の包丁が。」
助手「犯人の包丁。」
ℋ「そう。
つまり犯人は…
この中にいる！！！」